but uh like I mentioned that fear that
anxiety could be there could creep up
every once in a while do you do you feel
that and especially stressful moments
sort of outside of the Jujitsu met just
at work
stressful moments big decision days big
decision moments how do you deal with
that fear how do you deal with that
anxiety the thing that stresses me out
the most is always is always the people
challenges you know I kind of think that
um you know strategy questions
you know I tend to have enough
conviction around the values of what
we're trying to do and
what I think matters and what I want our
company to stand for that
those don't really keep me up at night
that much I mean I I kind of it's not
that I I get everything right of course
I don't right I mean make we make a lot
of mistakes but um
but I at least have a pretty strong
sense of where I want us to go on that
the the thing in in running a company
for you know almost 20 years now one of
the things that's been pretty clear is
when you have
a team that's cohesive
you can get
almost anything done and you know you
can you can run through super hard
challenges
um you can make hard decisions and push
really hard to to do the best work even
you know and kind of optimize something
super well but when when there's that
tension I mean that's that's when when
things get really tough and you know
when I talk to other friends who run
other companies and things like that I
think one of the things that I actually
spend a disproportionate amount of time
on in running this company is just
fostering a pretty tight core group of
of people who are running the company uh
with me and that to me is is kind of the
thing that
both makes it fun right having having
you know friends and people you've
worked with for a while and new people
and New Perspectives but like a pretty
tight group who can who you can go work
on some of these crazy things with
um but to me that's also the most
stressful thing is when when there are
when there's tension
um you know that's that that weighs on
me I think the you know just it's it's
it's maybe not surprising I mean we're
like a very people focused company and
it's the the people is the the part of
it that that
um you know weighs on me the most to
make sure that we get right but yeah
that that I'd say across everything that
we do is probably
the the big thing so when there's
tension in that inner circle of of close
folks so
when you trust those folks to help you
make difficult decisions
about uh Facebook WhatsApp Instagram the
future of the company and the metaverse
or the AI
uh how do you build that close-knit
group of folks uh to make those
difficult decisions is there people that
you have to have critical voices very
different perspectives on yeah focusing
on the past versus the future all that
kind of stuff yeah I mean I think for
one thing it's just spending a lot of
time with whatever the group is that you
want to be that Core Group
grappling with all of the biggest
challenges and that requires a fair
amount of openness
and you know so I mean a lot of how I I
run the company is you know it's like
every Monday morning we get our it's
about the top 30 people together and we
and this is a group that just worked
together for a long period of time and I
mean people people rotate in I mean new
people join people leave the company
people go do other roles in the company
so it's not the the same group over time
but then we spend you know a lot of
times a couple of hours a lot of the
time it's you know can be somewhat
unstructured we like I'll come with
maybe a few topics that I that are top
of mind for me but I'll ask other people
to bring things and people you know
raise questions whether it's okay
there's an issue happening in some
country
um with with some policy issue there's
like a new technology that's developing
here we're having an issue with this
partner
um you know there's a design trade-off
and WhatsApp between two things that
that end up
um being values that we care about
deeply and we need to kind of decide
where we want to be on that and I just
think over time
when um you know by working through a
lot of issues with people and doing it
openly people develop an intuition for
each other and a bond in camaraderie
um and to me developing that is is like
a lot of the fun part of running a
company or doing anything right I think
it's like having having people who are
kind of along on the journey that you're
that you feel like you're doing it with
nothing is ever just one person doing it
other people that disagree although oh
yeah within that group it's a fairly
combative group okay so combat is part
of it so this is making decisions on
design engineering
uh policy everything everything
everything